eu countries have reached a deal on
making emergency gas cuts this winter
europe is facing an energy crisis as the
russian-owned firm gazprom reduces
supplies from the nordstream 1 pipeline
from wednesday supplies will be just 20
of capacity half
of what they were in june
european energy ministers have held an
emergency meeting in brussels to discuss
their response russia says the
disruption is due to maintenance issues
and sanctions but the eu disputes that
we know that there is no technical
reason to do so this is a politically
motivated step and we have to be ready
for that and exactly for that reason
preemptive reduction of our gas demand
is a a wise
strategy
live now to brussels al jazeera's
abdullah al-shami joins us from there so
abdullah um what exactly of eu ministers
agreed
well the the the agreement that came
just um in an hour ago it was uh based
on the fact that uh all these state
members will go through a voluntary
reduction of their gas consumption
starting from the 1st of august all the
way till the 1st of march
2023
this voluntary reduction would be turned
into a mandatory one if the eu as cited
in the statement that came out if the eu
sees a security alert or security threat
to its uh gas supplies it will indeed
turn this into uh this uh mandatory uh
way of enforcing these cuts the eu aims
to store about 45 billion cubes cubic
meters of gas for this next winter and
at the same time the eu has also given
exemptions to member states who are not
part of the european gas network and
indeed at that point they will not have
to enforce the
mandatory gas costs if it has to come to
it so the eu has been able to kind of
come to midway between the countries
that saw it as you know
not really possible to enforce this kind
of mandatory cuts at the same time being
able to secure what it says it needs for
the next winter abdullah how was this
deal reached were eu states unified in
their response
well uh at the beginning of this meeting
this morning there was no uh that sense
of unity we we've seen countries like
portugal and poland as well as countries
from central europe uh as hungary that
in fact even threatened to go on its own
and have its own separate agreements
with russia because the eu handles
through the commission all the
agreements in terms of the power
supplies and the energy supplies in
general so the eu was able to come this
agreement after kind of conceding the
the part where it comes to mandatory
cuts uh it it said that these uh
these cuts will not be imposed uh for
the countries that has their own uh
special needs as cited in the statement
and at the same time it also gave the
option that if five countries or five
members of the eu ask for this cuts to
be imposed that will also happen so it
was that midpoint that the eu
you know has been able to reach just
a few uh minutes before the start of the
press conference in which uh this
statement will be announced officially
and thus it probably will be able to
save that is needed for the next winter
but still the eu commissioner for energy
says that they are ready for anything
that comes out of russia if that
disruption happens they are ready and
they are already waiting uh for supplies
that will come very soon from outside of
the european continent from countries
like egypt and israel al jazeera's
abdullah al-shami reporting live there
from brussels abdullah many thanks
indeed well that eu meeting came just
hours after ukraine's president vladimir
zelinski again accused russia of
inflicting what he called terror on
europe by restricting gas supplies
today we saw a new gas threat to europe
despite the nordstrom turbine concession
russia is not planning to resume gas
supply to european countries as it is
obliged to do all this is done by russia
on purpose there is an open gas war that
russia is waging against united europe
they do not care what will happen to the
people how they will suffer from hunger
due to the blocking of ports or from
winter cold and poverty or from
occupation these are just different
forms of terror